on en débat tout de suite avec nos
invités eric berlivet mère génération
terrain de la roche la molière dans la
loire et jacques myard mer et l'air de
maisons laffitte dans les yvelines
bonsoir à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france d'abord dans quel
état d'esprit vous êtes après les
annonces d'olive et veyran hier soir
eric d'arrivée je me tourne vers vous là
bas
dans quel état d'esprit toute façon on
est un petit peu rodé maintenant depuis
quelques mois un des décisions qui
change très rapidement et donc comme
tout bon maire que l'on mais il faut
qu'on s'adapte très rapidement de façon
efficace pour qu'on puisse trouver des
solutions sur le terrain donc on est sur
le terrain et on s'adapte voilà c'est ça
notre état d'esprit
jacques maire vous êtes dans le même
état d'esprit écoutez il est évident
qu'on subit les choses aujourd'hui et
que on ne voit pas très bien ce qu'on
doit faire en priorité
il est clair que aujourd'hui le
gouvernement démarrent les vaccinations
avec un retard qui est stupéfiant
stupéfiants et donc à ce titre on ne
comprend pas pourquoi alors que 500
milles vaccins sont arrivés en france qu
on a vacciné jusqu'à présent que
quelques dizaines de personnes de plus
parler d'un couvre-feu parler d'un
confinement
alors qu'on sait très bien que c'est
reculer pour mieux sauter c'est pas ça
qui va résoudre la chose la seule
possibilité c'est effectivement que il
faut absolument commencer en masse les
mac sain et je suis stupéfait de
constater que véritablement ça patine
pour parler aux élites berlivet vous
êtes d'accord avec un jacques nerfs dans
tout ce que vous vous êtes un signataire
d'ailleurs d'un manifeste de karl olive
qui est le cofondateur de votre
mouvement le maire de poissy qui appelle
les maires à se faire vacciner en
appelant justement à à l'exemplarité des
mères oui de problème il ya le problème
de la fourniture et de la distribution
et de des vaccins dans nos pays et le
problème de des français qui sont un peu
réticents à la vaccination
et c'est pour ça qu'on propose avec
génération terrain et dont tu remets à
tous les maires qui sont volontaires de
montrer l'exemple parce que on
quand même crédible nous mr on est assez
écoutée de nos concitoyens on est
apportée d'engueulades et apporter aussi
de service donc forcément les gens nous
connaissent et donc peut-être de montrer
l'exemple en nous faisant vacciner
devant eux leur disant voilà on y va
suivez-nous pour que le maximum de gens
se fassent vacciner on le fait pas
forcément pour nous on fait pour les
autres surtout un c'est un signe
d'intelligence et de deux démarches
collectives donc je pense que c'est
important mais c'est vrai que comme le
dit mon collègue de maisons laffitte
il ya un souci peut-être de distribution
aux organisations en france parce qu'on
a une lourdeur administrative qui est
tellement lourde que la réactivité n'est
pas forcément toujours au rendez vous
jacques maire je crois que vous n'avez
pas signé justement ce manifeste si vous
l'avez fait d'accord donc vous y adhérez
vous vous y adhérez à 100%
il ya un devoir d'exemplarité de la part
des élus
c'est un problème d'exemplarité et c'est
aussi pour dire à nos concitoyens qui
sont sceptiques
attention ne jouais pas trop avec le feu
on voit très bien que la la vaccination
a permis par exemple d'éradiquer la
poliomyélite la variole et donc
aujourd'hui ce vaccin il ya eu une
mauvaise communication au début parce
que la technique de la rn a été présenté
comme quelque chose qui n'avait pas été
utilisé dans le passé et l excellent
calme nous a dit non pas du tout
c'est une méthode qu'on utilise pour
combattre le cancer depuis des années et
des années
donc on n'est pas dans je dirais une
terra incognita
on est dans une méthode qui a qui
commence à faire ses preuves
donc il faut dire à nos concitoyens et
les maires bien évidemment son parti de
ce combat regarder les choses en face
c'est la seule solution le vaccin pour
qu'on s'en sorte
donc n'ayez pas peur et on voir jusqu'à
présent
jusqu'à présent je touche du bois route
à pension la tête
il est évident que
il n'y a pas eu je dirais de de
contre-indication durable il ya eu
quelques personnes qui avaient la tête
un peu paralysés mais ça ne durait pas
donc je crois que c'est la seule
solution et il faut dédramatiser ce
vaccin j'ajoute une chose c'est que nous
les maires comme mon collègue ici
présent nous sommes capables non pas de
vacciner mais de mettre à disposition
des endroits des gymnases des salles
pour pouvoir recevoir nos concitoyens
par exemple en matière de tests à
maisons laffitte
pendant une semaine on a testé plus de
700 personnes
donc on voit bien qu'on est capable
d'apporter les moyens matériels
logistiques pour faire face alors vous
faisiez allusion à l'excès ricains d'un
généticien qui lui a dit regretter
justement le la lenteur dans la
stratégie de cette campagne de
vaccination on va y revenir mais puisque
vous faites référence ou devoir
d'exemplarité des élus vous regrettez
que les membres du gouvernement et que
des membres aussi des autorités de santé
ne soit pas sur la même longueur d'onde
que joue pourquoi ne se ferait pas
vacciner devant les caméras par exemple
ça pourrait inciter effectivement les
français à se faire vacciner massivement
qu'en pensez vous juste un point on va
pas faire du voyeurisme bonk la reine
d'angleterre se vaccine etc
moi je veux bien que le président de la
république aussi mais là c'est une
question on n'est pas là pour faire de
la communication s'était passé jacques
tenir c'était le cas le week-end dernier
vous avez peut-être vu dimanche il y
avait aussi un cardiologue qui s'est
fait vacciner devant les caméras oui
mais ce qui est beaucoup plus grave chez
que visuellement il n'y a pas un plan
d'urgence pour vacciner le personnel de
santé
ça c'est un problème est là je crois que
il faut que le gouvernement met le
paquet et je le comprends pas cette
lenteur eric est un dérivé oui alors en
fait on a un souci d'intelligence
collective et de coordination
en fait les welsches sont un peu grippée
peut-être au niveau national on a en a
des possibilités dans nos communes sur
ma commune j'ai une entreprise qui
fabrique des containers isotherme pour
transporter les vaccins qui va
distribuer dans l'ensemble de la france
justement ces vaccins il faut qu'on ait
une harmonie que la rs
dans chaque région au corps en donne on
a les moyens sur les communes dans les
départements dans les régions de
coordonner tout ça le problème c'est
qu'on sait pas qui fait quoi et des fois
on voit que sur le terrain nous on est
là pour pallier aux manques ou
questionnement qu'on peut se poser on
est là et comme comme dans d'autres
communes on est tous aussi disponible
pour préparer pour accueillir pour
organiser les choses en attaque
personnelle
les gens les bénévoles on a tout ce
qu'il faut pour coordonner chose mais il
faut qu'on donne le tempo et qui a un
rythme soutenu est ce que vous pourriez
suivre par exemple l'initiative de du mr
estrosi qui lui annoncé une campagne
anticipée
une campagne de vaccination anticipée
pardon je suis fort heureux d'apprendre
qu'il a récupéré des vaccins parce que
pense pour l'instant en ce qui concerne
la ville de maisons-laffitte
même si je ne suis pas maisons laffitte
aujourd'hui il n'en demeure pas moins
que je n'ai eu aucune connaissance que
la rs nous a dit attention on arrive
avec 1000 2000 bacso ou qu'on va
vacciner en priorité dans les ehpad
pour l'instant on est comme l'oiseau sur
la branche la branche
on attend et c'est à la rs véritablement
de nous informer le plus rapidement
possible et libyens vivent et on est ce
qu'à votre avis on est confronté à un
problème de stocks parlons franchement
en fait on n'a pas d'information si on
avait de l'information seraient les
premiers à acheter des vaccins comme on
était les premiers à acheter des masques
commandés été les premiers à acheter des
tests mais il faut qu'on ait ces vaccins
pour qu'on puisse y distribuer donne de
bonnes conditions mais aujourd'hui on
n'a pas d'informations en tout cas les
autorités annoncent un million de doses
disponibles dans courant du mois de
janvier
le manque ça c'est un fusion certes mais
je crois que à ce moment là il va
falloir organiser la priorité des
priorités
moi je pense que les personnes âgées
serre mais aussi les personnels
soignants et donc ça va poser quand même
quelques problèmes d'éthique et il est
urgent que la france qui a aujourd'hui
reçu 500 mille doses
il paraît que la semaine prochaine on va
en avoir cinq cent mille nouvelles et
bien comment
en puissance rapidement mais je crains
fort que healy à latence qui risque de
peser lourdement sur l'état
psychologique de nos concitoyens une
dernière question quand vous voyez la
campagne les campagnes de vaccination
s'accélère et ailleurs c'est le cas on
en parlait tout à l'heure avec philippe
froguel au royaume uni il ya ce vaccin
astrazeneca qui a été donc autorisé là
bas cela vous inquiète pour les mois à
venir en france on a un système qui
normalement oui j'ai juste on a un
système de santé qui est très performant
en france normalement et qui est reconnu
dans le monde entier et c'est vrai que
là on est à buté à une problématique de
stocks et de deux on sait que dans
beaucoup d'autres pays ont tout à
l'heure vous avez évoqué le vaccin qui
vient de russie
d'autres vaccins qui viennent
d'angleterre luis le protège où ils se
gardent pour eux on n'a pas eu une
stratégie peut-être de d'anticiper les
choses alors je n'ai pas mal et de faire
surtout quand on est en europe avec ses
contraintes et ses avantages mais
beaucoup de contraintes donc ça arrange
pas forcément les choses mais quand en
europe on est fermé en vaccins spoutnik
c'est un choc nerveux
le mot de la fin pour vous oh vous savez
ce n'est pas le mot de la fin
c'est plus exactement que le combat
continue que les maires vont se
mobiliser sur la vàd soir car nous
sommes au contact de la population
mais il faut aussi que nous ayons les
moyens et notamment il n'y a pas que les
moyens de vaccin car il pourra se voir
aussi le personnel car dans un certain
nombre de villes nous manquons vous le
savez de médecins et d'infirmières
donc j'espère qu'il va y avoir une
mobilisation va falloir faire revenir
sans doute les réservistes c'est à dire
les retraités pour qu'ils viennent
vacciner ça c'est un défi également qui
va qu'il va devoir être relevé mais bon
j'espère qu'on en sortira
le point jeunes majeurs c'est l'arrivée
des vaccins en nombre et en quantité en
france et là visiblement s'attarde merci
beaucoup à vous jacques myard amer l air
de maisons laffitte et eric bell
iv mère général son terrain de roche la
molière dans la loire